lui c'est benji venu d'une autre planète
avec son frère et sa soeur
ils doivent se fondre dans la masse et
tenté de cacher leur pouvoir trois
personnages attachants héros de la bande
dessinée super pour leurs dessinateurs
le festival de la bd de tours c'est
l'occasion de quitter son atelier et
rencontrer son public donc c'est
toujours sympa en plus mobiles comme
celle de la jeunesse gérer un public
d'enfants donc c'est plutôt familiale
donc c'est toujours mignon fin on est on
a envie de leur faire plaisir de leur
faire un petit dessin donc pour ça c'est
toujours agréable comme lui cinquante
auteurs participeront ce week-end au
festival à tour de bulles histoire de
montrer toute la richesse de la bande
dessinée dont nos choix parmi les
auteurs invités on essaye de choisir des
auteurs pour présenter un panel très
large de ce qui ce fait qui va des
auteurs jeunesse à de l'historique de la
sf l'autobiographie enfin mots durs en
portage
maintenant voilà quoi un événement
incontournable pour les libraires chaque
année il organise des dédicaces et font
découvrir au public des auteurs
notamment locaux il ya beaucoup
d'auteurs qui sont venus s'installer à
tour la ville compte deux ateliers
principal qui regroupent à eux deux une
petite vingtaine d'auteurs qui sont
leurs ya des auteurs qui font de la
bande dessinée puis d'autres qui se
diversifient seins nus graphisme la
communication sur le thème de l'italie
des expositions des ateliers ou encore
des conférences rythmeront tout le week
end